and dr. Stein I assume you've been on
medication at beth israel deaconess
getting over the campaign the news flow
has been fast and furious and let us
first talk about voter fraud by every
report it's not out there how do people
on common ground in Congress convince
the administration and convince the
president there's other things to talk
about well I think that applies to so
many things in addition to voter fraud
you know we we have we've got a
healthcare crisis and undermining the
little bit of health care support we
have for example is not the way to go
but on voter fraud you know I think we
just have to point out over and over the
problem is voter suppression not voter
fraud and again this is an effort of the
President to distract from his uh shall
we say rather humiliating loss of the
popular vote and to blame it once again
on immigrants and just to bring more
hatred and divisions the hot stove
league is in full force in baseball
we're counting down the days till spring
training with the Red Sox forget about
that I want to count down the days until
the Democratic Party recovers looking at
voter fraud looking at these other
issues what is your prescription for
liberals in Trump America yeah I'm you
know I think Trump's the vote for Donald
Trump remember was not for Donald Trump
the majority of Trump voters were
actually voting against Hillary Clinton
you know I think we've been dragged
around by the Democratic Party for long
enough I think neither the Democrats nor
the Republicans are providing the
America that we need every day people
are being thrown under the bus it's gone
on long enough I think we need a new
independent politics which is what the
largest group of voters is actually
calling for they have divorced the
Democratic and Republican parties my
advice is don't be lulled to sleep again
and go back into the same party which
has not reformed which still has the
same super-delegates which still is
buried in lobbyists and
corporate money they have no intention
to reform it's time for us to stand up
with a politics of by and for the people
Jill can I change gears to excuse the
pun a little bits can I ask you about
Elon Musk's apparent new relationship
with the White House and Donald Trump he
has for many people become the
cheerleader for the for the
environmental story and he now seems to
have a very good at almost a special
relationship with Donald Trump what do
you make of that you know I am not sure
what his relationship is and I don't
know what he is advocating in terms of
the environment but it's clear that
Donald Trump is taking his his guidance
from you know the people he's appointed
to his cabinet which you know in in more
departments than just the EPA and
interior and Department of Energy you
know he's got the Secretary of State for
that matter you know they're all inside
the the usual circle of the fossil fuel
predatory companies that are now they
don't need lobbyists anymore they are
directly in charge of our government dr.
Stein before we let you go I must ask
you about the Affordable Care Act if we
get Trump health what will it mean for
the doctors and nurses of America um you
know I think the real critical question
is what does it mean for the people of
America right now the health care
providers have had it up to here with
the complexities of our privatized
healthcare system and it's not getting
better it's only getting more complex
more full of paperwork more full of
bureaucracy from the privatized
insurance companies we keep adding layer
upon layer of bureaucracy it's not good
for providers it's not good for patients
we need health care as a human right
through a simplified streamlined
Medicare for all that's the direction we
need to go that solution is within our
hands and I'll just conclude saying what
we need is for
every day people to stand up like we've
been standing up and to lead the way
forward like under Richard Nixon you
know a very corrupt and oppressive
president we brought the troops home
from Vietnam got the Clean Air Act Clean
Water Act Environmental Protection
Agency we even got women's right to
choose Andres conservative Supreme Court
by us standing up and leading the way
forward to the world we deserve